anyone here a quick porn story yeah okay
so I worked out of this like it never
gave a nod of approval I work out of
this office called the founders dojo and
it was the greatest thing ever
I'll tell another story about it but
basically it was if you've seen the TV
show Silicon Valley it was we had Erlich
Bachman it was an Erlich Bachman type of
guy named Dave who was a great guy but
totally inappropriate and disgusting in
a good way and the office was filthy and
there was this guy I forget his name
ritesh and Chris yeah and I remember and
it was this little skinny Indian guy and
he was crazy and awesome and he was like
the stereotypical Silicon Valley hacker
where he could get a job at any big
company and make $200,000 a year but he
was like no [__] that I'm like nah I'm
[__] the corporate pigs right and so
he would sleep at that office and Dave
would buy them pizza all the time
because he was like get one to be poor
and do this thing and so he created a
app or know a size a website that would
crawl tumblr no I think all the internet
okay for the fascists for the gifs that
had the highest velocity of growth and
so if a Jif launched popular gifs he
would tell you right away which one's
gonna be the most popular and then you
would see it on the screen and it was
called the worst drug the worst drug dot
TV it's not there anymore and that
sounds like a silly thing but that's not
why he did it he did it because what he
was trying to do was a find the fastest
like technology that could find fast
growing stuff and if you would go to the
worst drug at Tom you could type in
something like dog and the search
feature would autofill like wicked fast
like way faster and then you would click
enter and it would be BAM a high-def
Jeff there's a high death it was full
screen and it was all screen laser fast
so the technology is very like pod Piper
like the technology wasn't like whatever
pop Piper did it was the fact that it
was all behind these scenes like a bunch
of nerds being like yeah our gifs load
the fastest and like look it's like HD
and it happened in nanoseconds and he
would spend nights and I would come back
and it would be just a tiny improvement
but we don't gather on it well so here's
the cut this the the point of the story
turns out the most popular gifs on the
Internet 99% of them are
super hardcore raunchy porn like real
raunchy porn and so because when I went
to the site it was all porn there wasn't
like porn and then some basketball
Cheers
funny one it was only porn I was like
this is a porn site and so at the
opposite the dojo
we would have these huge screens of like
his work station and the way that he sat
was everyone can see it and we kind of
got immune to it but it was like the
Rocchi should ever and we would he'd
like guys check this out early the
morning we would come in 11:00 a event
which was early and he be rubbing his
eyes and [__] and he'd be like check
this out and all eight of us would
gather up as hi-def screen and be like
and he would type in the word like like
facial and like because like watch how
fast it slows and we were just so immune
we're like they're not even looking at
the content like oh yeah wow you could
like see the shine in the liquid like it
was so funny we would have like these
like lawyers come into the office and
people who are actually are like
investors who would try to raise money
for the other companies and we would
forget that this was on the big screen
what happened this like what's this guy
doing now on the site the site the worst
drug got millions of millions of
millions of visitors the engagement was
stupidly like good
he couldn't monetize it they couldn't
use it so there were so many
restrictions no ad network or a lot him
to use it and so even though the site I
think it was getting at least for sure
millions I think maybe tens of millions
of monthly uniques and it made zero
money it only cost him a lot of money
and the story ends with like someone in
Bulgaria are laughs eeeh like this like
communist ex communist country wanted to
buy the site and it was all weird they
flew him out there and he's like wait
these guys are like mobsters and they
ended up like bailing and they just shut
it down because it what does he do now
he works at Facebook I've never seen
them transfer dodge that's his name Raj
I've never seen Raj because that guy is
gonna build something amazing or it's
gonna be a very sad ending but either
way it's gonna be not average not to use
yeah he was he was like if you think of
like this idea of what Silicon Valley is
that was that right Wow
[Music]